Hi, welcome back to visual Baltic. I'm grunt over the past few decades.
Technology has transformed our world radically and in every way,
thanks to technological advances.
The lifestyle we enjoy today has very little to do with the lifestyle that our
parents led, let alone our growth.
Parents, things like that.
Being able to monitor your pulse in real time,
generate automatic graphs of your cardiac activity through your smartphone
control.
Every last parameter of your physical activity always be connected with your
friends and family or the facts that you can have business meetings from your
beach apartment by video conference would have sounded like madness until just a
few years ago. No, like everything in this world,
it's not all as rosy as it seems.
Technological advancement has also brought with it some dome sites.
And of course,
we can also find double standards as to how States and some multinationals use
technology for purposes that are maybe not so good.
Especially when we talk about technologies that allow the monitoring and
tracking of people's activity.
But check out the start of 2020 has been a good example of the potential of new
technologies for dealing with health crises, such as the one with SARS cov two,
for example, in many countries,
digital applications are currently being used to track and geo-locate citizens
who may have been in contact with infected persons or places.
By voice or location is really apps can determine your risk of
coronavirus. But times of Israel.
Good example is that, uh, South Korea,
where one of the greatest successes in the prevention of infection and the early
detection of SARS cov two cases has come from the intensive use of technological
means even to controversial limits.
South Korea, to impose tracking wristband for defying quarantine orders,
Bloomberg.
I think we talk about in great detail and a video we made about how South Korea
has dealt with the Corona virus. The link is in the description.
Now.
Of course, this use of technology doesn't always go so smoothly.
As you can imagine,
such applications and tracking systems may sometimes have flaws. Listen up.
Two days, holed up in my bedroom,
thanks to a buggy health ministry virus app times of Israel.
Wasting two days in your bedroom may not seem so banned. However,
beyond this kind of anecdotal mess up other much more important dangers lurk,
I guess,
problem presented by these new technologies has to do mainly with the new
capacity of States to control their people.
Yeah.
Yes. Okay.
You may be watching this from solid democracies from countries where essential
freedoms are guaranteed. And all of this is something that today,
at least for today will not consume.
But think how different situation could be.
And dictator led countries or by governments with fuse.
Triples, it's such cases.
These new technological capabilities can become a real weapons of solutions.
Control sync.
For example,
in the case of you guessed to China using the Corona virus as an excuse,
the government has extended and generalized geolocation systems that are highly
intrusive and people's private lives systems that have gone far beyond simply.
Tracking.
Taking advantage of this crisis to boost social codes that have existed for some
years, such as the new.
Hell's coat. These are codes.
The rate individuals based on certain parameters and determine whether or not
those individuals can do certain things.
Things as crazy.
Is that my son, but what does all this really mean? Where's the danger?
Are they temporary measures or will they become permanent?
Even once the coronavirus crisis is no longer a threat.
What can the Chinese government do with these new identification and geolocation.
Technologies to learn more about this issue.
This video,
we are going to tell you how technology is also changing the way States
governments are monitoring our lives.
And this way we will try to address the risks that may arise.
No, no, no.
I don't think we're just going to talk to you about China. Believe me.
I bet there are things you're going to hear in this video are going to amaze you.
China from dictatorship to police state.
No,
I'm sure many of you have heard the China has one of the most advanced social
surveillance technologies in the world,
especially when we consider their application on a massive scale.
Something.
During the coronavirus pandemic to establish systems of surveillance,
restrictions and prohibitions, like never.
For before.
For example, about the infamous health code,
which uses the colors of a traffic light to classify people according to whether
or not they have recovered from the Corona virus,
whether they have had any contact with people who had it,
or whether they've visited high risk areas.
This system was initially developed by the hung zoo, local government,
but has spread throughout the country. It is currently installed on Weechat,
Chinese WhatsApp and Ali pay. Alibaba is payment platform.
Well, as we.
Chat and Wickson, it's Chinese version have 1.1,
6 million users and Ali pay about 900 million.
We can say that virtually all Chinese citizens have at least one of those two
applications that they use every day. Well,
many functions have been restricted or conditioned by the health code.
But how.
Exactly does this traffic late talking of citizens.
Work?
Let's see, there are several ways on the hand,
if health authorities determined that you have,
or recently had the coronavirus or that you've been in contact with an infected
person, then you will be given the rent status.
Then if contact is not so obvious,
you just also have to fill out a questionnaire, which combined with other data,
such as geolocation through mobiles,
determines your chances of having been exposed or having been close to the
virus.
And this way you could be classified as yellow or at best as green,
the green color is the one that gives you almost absolute freedom within the
current restrictions. And look,
don't think for a moment that it's something only used by a few,
not at all in China,
these health codes are being used for almost everything to allow access to the
subway, to go shopping, to go to a restaurant, to a cafe,
even to authorize payments for plane or train tickets
and short life.
The freedom of many people now revolves around the color they have been
assigned. Yes, this may seem like a story taken from black mirror,
but what we're telling you is what's already working. There's no Saifai here.
Surely many of you are thinking, but what's wrong with all this.
At the end of the day,
it's a really effective tool for fighting the Corona virus.
Isn't that what's made China so successful in controlling the spread of the
pandemic. Well,
let's see the problem is,
and the indiscriminate use that our government can make of these tools.
Indeed, the use of such technologies in China to control or restrict freedoms.
It's not something that is only a resident as a result of the coronavirus
crisis. And of course, as we all know,
China is not exactly the poster child for human rights and civil liberties.
It's more like the opposite. In fact,
what seems to be happening is that the Corona virus is being used as the perfect
excuse to popularize and perpetuate measures as controversial or sensitive.
As these check out.
China is installing surveillance cameras outside people's front doors,
and sometimes inside their homes. After a trip to Southern China,
the 34 year old Irish ex-pat and his family were starting their two week home
quarantine,
a mandatory measure enforced by the Beijing government to stop the spread of the
novel coronavirus.
You said he opened the door as the camera was being installed. Without warning,
having a camera outside your door is an incredible erosion of privacy.
And I don't know how much of it is actually legal CNN.
Cameras, even on the front door at home. Are you surprised? Well,
you shouldn't be
the things that are being put into practice during this health crisis have been
in the pipeline for many years. Indeed.
China has cities where it is virtually impossible to escape the eyes of the
authorities. To give you an idea. Nationally,
there are about 200 million surveillance cameras and some cities have literally
become a kind of begged brother set,
For example, and this idea of brace yourself,
cause I'm going to butcher this Chung yang,
the most monitored setting on the planet 2019 ended with over two and a half
million surveillance cameras for 15.5, 3 million inhabitants.
That is one camera for every 5.9. Okay.
Habitats.
The most troubling thing from the point of view of privacy and freedom are
advances in facial recognition techniques for surveillance purposes,
a subject in which China is the undisputed leader worldwide.
Right?
Well take for example, brace yourself,
Zang zoo and industrial setting located in the central part of the country.
Here.
Authorities have massively combined video surveillance with Telekom tracking to
create one of the most advanced and accurate facial detection systems in the
world.
And how does it work?
Well,
the police have white boxes that are mobile antenna trackers installed next to
many of the surveillance.
And this way the image is captured by the cameras can match people's faces with
their mobile phones and their geo positioning so that the system can determine
whether the person detected by the camera is really the one. And that.
Please.
The question is what does the Chinese regime want? All this technology?
Well.
You find a clue to what weights,
the Chinese and the near future and the coastal city of wrong champ. Once again,
I apologize to any Chinese people watching I'm Scottish. I barely speak English.
Hello.
Works is that each of the 670,000 inhabitants of the city of Rome,
Chang receives 1000 citizen points and depending on how they behave and what
they do, they can lose or Aaron points. For example,
you're fighting with your neighbor five points deducted.
Don't do what you have to do when you take the dog out 10 points,
go donate blood. And five more points.
Of course you can forget speaking out against the authorities or make any
negative comments about the political economic or social situation of the
country, because then things could get very, very complicated for you.
Very fast.
Like the system,
the authorities have set a rent list of actions and activities and daily life
that may or may not be undertaken depending on the number of points you have.
For example, if you lose a certain level of points,
then your most basic freedoms,
such as mobility begin to be restricted and watch out because we're talking
about a system that could prevent you from accessing a bank loan or even booking.
Green tickets.
You sink, it seems a bit crazy, doesn't it? Well,
they're pilot schemes at the moment,
but the risk of them being rolled out across the country seem to be increasing
each day.
And that's skating with the Chinese government's use of these technologies.
The Chinese dictatorship could always know we're an opponent or simply a suspect
in one might be.
They could also know precisely what people they have met with and what places
they frequent.
I guess you can get an idea of what this may mean in terms of individual
freedoms. Overall, it's not looking at.
Good.
If this seems like something incredible that could only happen in countries like
China. Well,
you may be surprised to learn that in countries that we consider free,
the use of surveillance technologies for social monitoring is not as rare or as
uncommon as we might originally think. Let's take a look.
Troll a universal vice. So first of all.
A question,
do you think it's justified to undermine the privacy of people in public spaces
and exchange for greater.
Security?
No, this is a complex issue.
And the truth is that I don't think there was a clear answer to any of this.
There are people who prioritize privacy and freedom above all else and others
who would say that security is much more.
However.
Other things we are seeing today,
even outside China make us wonder whether perhaps the path has been set in some
countries is not exactly the most appropriate.
Yes.
Several countries considered free and democratic such as the United States or
especially the United Kingdom,
which you're also trying to develop Chinese style.
Facial detection systems who'd look in the UK, we've all got terrible teeth.
We'll see how that works. Of course today,
the limitations of technology fortunately, or unfortunately,
depending on whoever is looking at it are still very sick.
Okay.
A test conducted by the police in South Wales and the United Kingdom with a
camera detection system called Neo face,
determined that during the 55 hours and operation of the 2,900 possible marches,
only 145 were real positive.
That means only 145 were posted the facial surveys of the right person.
See what I mean.
About the teeth?
It's clear that this technological gap can be closed very quickly. Listen up.
London police are taking surveillance to a whole new level London's police
department said that it would begin using facial recognition to spot criminal
suspects with video cameras. As they walk the streets,
adopting a level of surveillance that is rare outside China, the New York times,
you did hear that.
Correctly.
The British capital wants to make use of more than the 627,000 surveillance
cameras spread throughout the city.
The largest infrastructure of this cane on the entire European continent.
We're talking about 68 cameras for every one site.
Londoners.
Clearly the result of the use of these systems will not be the same in the
country like the United Kingdom as an autocratic, China, but privacy,
privacy seems increasingly doomed.
And that forces us to ask ourselves a few questions.
Is it justified to expand video surveillance in the name of security and to
every corner of our lanes?
Should we accept that governments be provided with the localization data from
our smartphones to eventually resolve a crime what's more important to you,
security or privacy?
Is it possible to reach a happy medium or do you think there will always be a
tendency to monitor more and more and more and an upcoming video we'll look in
detail at some such plans put in place by some of the world's most powerful
governments, but at the moment, we'd love to know your opinion.
We really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like and subscribe.
If you didn't have you had the little bell down there, you'll hear from us.
Whenever we put our new videos up, we put ones up every few days.
Also please consider checking out our friends at the reconsidered media podcast,
they provided the vocals and this episode that we're not my dulcet tones. Also,
this channel is possible because of Patrion on our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you in the next video.
Or more about politics and world affairs.
And here's some more of my lovely voice.
Check out the reconsidered podcast where we don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite pod catcher.
[inaudible].